a lot of people have thought that the
key to AI is the learning algorithm and
I actually don't believe it's the
learning algorithm I think teaching is
what makes the difference so from a
philosophical standpoint I believe that
machine learning algorithm is almost the
easy part is the part that you can
locally akima as teaching is the part
that you have to optimize at a global
level at a societal level and I think
that may actually be the key to AI the
same way it was the key to human
development you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it
I'm your host Gretchen Hughes Inga
machine learning is a powerful tool that
enables computers to learn by observing
the world recognizing patterns and
self-training via experience much like
humans but while machines perform well
when they can extract knowledge from
large amounts of labelled data their
learning outcomes remain vastly inferior
to humans when data is limited
that's why dr. Patrice Samar
distinguished engineer and head of the
machine teaching group at Microsoft is
using actual teachers to help machines
learn and enable them to extract
knowledge from humans rather than just
data today doctors Samar tells us why he
believes any task you can teach to a
human you should be able to teach to a
machine he explains how machines can
exploit the human ability to decompose
and explain concepts to trained ml
models more efficiently and less
expensively and gives us an innovative
vision of how and a human teacher and a
machine learning model work together in
a real-time interactive process domain
experts can leverage the power of
machine learning without machine
learning expertise that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Patrese Samar welcome to the podcast
thank you this is a pleasure to be here
I have to start a little differently
than I normally do because you and I are
talking at a literal transition point
for you
until recently I would have introduced
you as distinguished engineer research
manager and deputy managing director of
Microsoft Research but you're just
moving along with a stellar team from
Microsoft Research to Microsoft Office
right yes this is going well we're gonna
talk about that in a minute
but first I always like to get a general
sense of what my guests do for a living
and why sort of in broad strokes what
are the problems you're trying to solve
in general and what gets you up in the
morning makes you want to come to work I
want to do innovation I think this is
where I have my background and talent so
I am completely reverent to the
established wisdom and I like to go and
try to solve problems and since I want
to change things I want to have an
impact in terms of change then I picked
the problem and try to reformulate it
and solve it in a different way or
change the question I think this is
usually the best way to have an impact
so that irreverence is that something
you've had since you were young is it
part of your sort of DNA yes the issue
there was that I was never really that
good in classrooms and I always somehow
misunderstood the question answered a
different question and since I didn't do
my homework very well I never knew what
the standard answer was and so I kept
changing the problem and that was not
very successful in class but when I
moved to research then changing the
question was actually part of the job
and so I got far more successful after I
got past this color program that's
actually hilarious because the school
system rewards people who get answers
right but over in research you want to
turn things on their head yes that's
what I mean changing the question is
formal useful in research then
coming up with different answer or
slightly better answer to an existing
question you know that's just a perfect
setup for this podcast because the
entire topic is turning a particular
discipline or field on its head a little
bit so let's set the stage for our
conversation today by operationalizing
the term machine teaching some people
have said it's just another way of
saying machine learning but you
characterized it as basically the next
new field for both programming and
machine learning so tell us how is
machine teaching a new paradigm and
what's so different about it that it
qualifies as a new field okay so I'm
gonna characterize machine learning as
extracting knowledge from data machine
teaching is different and the problem in
tries to solve is what if you start and
you have no data and then the task is
about extracting knowledge from the
teacher and this is very similar to
programming programming is about
extracting knowledge from the programmer
so this is where the two field are very
close and it's a very different pairing
because now it's all about expressivity
recognizing what the teacher meant and
because you focus on the teacher this is
why HCI is so important HCI is
human-computer interaction and so
programming and teaching or absolutely
the epitome of human communicating with
computers listen I want to ask cuz I'm
still a little fuzzy when you say you
have no data but you have a teacher is
this teacher a human is this teacher a
person yes yes explain what that looks
like with no data that is the teacher
giving the data to the Machine yes so
let me give you a simple example okay
imagine I want to teach you how to buy a
car so I want to give you my personal
feeling for how you buy a good car so I
could bring you to the parking lot and
point to good cars and bad cars and at
some point I may ask you what is a good
car and you may say oh it's all the
cause for which the second digit of the
license plate is even and that may fit
the data perfectly and obviously this is
not what I expected
this is not the way we do it human to
human so the way we do it human to human
is I will tell you that you should look
at the price you should look at crash
tests you should look at the gas mileage
maybe you should buy electric and these
are features they are what question to
ask to basically have the right answer
about what a good car in a bad car and
that's very different it's a little bit
like Socrates teaching by asking the
right question as opposed to a
numerating positive and negative for the
task so when human teacher the human
they teach in a very different way then
they teach a machine now if you have
millions and millions of label then the
task is about extracting the knowledge
from that data but if you start with no
data then you find out that labels are
not efficient at all and this is not the
way human teach other humans so there
must be another language and the other
language is what I call machine teaching
this is like a programming language and
just to give you an idea of how natural
it is what I see happen over and over in
industry is that when people want to
build a new machine learning model they
start by collecting a whole bunch of
data they write labeling directives and
then they outsource it and then they get
back their 50,000 labels and then have a
machine learning algorithm try to
extract that knowledge from those labels
but this is ironic because the labeling
directives contain all the information
to do the labeling so imagine now that
the labeling directives could be
inputted directly into the system now
when you look at the labeling directives
they are features they are saying oh
this is a cooking recipe because it has
a list of ingredient so if we can make
that the teaching language then we can
skip the middleman and get the machine
do the right thing that's exactly the
word I was going to use is the middleman
of the labelers right drilling in a
little teachers are typically more
expensive in terms of hours and so on so
what's the business model here except
for the fact that you're missing the
middleman which usually marks up the
price how is it more efficient or less
expensive
okay so this is exactly what happened
with programming at first the
programmers were scientist that would
program in assembly code and the name of
the game in those days was performance
and the biggest machine you could get in
the fastest machine you could get and
over the years the field has evolved to
allow more and more people to program
and the cost became really the
programmer and so we wanted to scale
with the number of programmers
this was the mythical man-month and you
know how to reduce the cost of
programmer how to scale a single task to
multiple programmers and if you look at
the literature for programming it moved
from a literature of performance to a
literature of productivity and I believe
that machine learning is still a
literature of performance generalization
is everything and if you have a lot of
data this is the right thing there I
mean basically what makes the difference
is the machine learning algorithm and
how many GPUs you're going to put on it
and this is what deep learning is and
I've worked in that field for many years
and I absolutely loved that game but I
believe that we are changing we are the
turning point where productivity and the
teachers time becomes more and more
important and for custom problems you
don't have a choice you cannot extract
the dollars from the data because you
don't have the data it's too custom or
maybe changes too fast and in that case
the more efficient way to communicate
the knowledge is through features to a
schema through other constraint and I'm
not sure we yet know what language it
will be it will still evolved
[Music]
as a former teacher myself albeit
teaching teens not machines I'm
intrigued by your framework of what we
in education called decomposition or
deconstructing down into smaller
concepts to help people understand and
then scaffolding or using building
blocks to support underlying knowledge
to build up for future learning talk
about how those concepts will transfer
from human teaching to machine teaching
so in philosophy there's a movement
called behaviorist that says that with
stimuli response you can teach
everything and of course you can't you
won't be able to learn very complex
things if you just do stimuli responds
well in machine learning I find that
very often a machine learning expert or
what I would call machine running
behaviorist and basically they believe
that with a very large set of input
label pair they can teach anything and
it turns out machine to a machine right
and if you have a tremendous amount of
labels and you have a tremendous amount
of computation you can go very far but
they are tasks that you will never be
able to do if I were to give you a
scenario and ask you to write a book you
could feel buildings of scenario garbage
and scenario book if you will not be
able to learn that task the space of
functions that are bad is too big
compared to the space of function that
actually fulfilled a desired goal and
because of that there's absolutely no
way you can select the right function
from the original space in a time that's
less than the length of the universe or
something so but strangely enough
everyone in this building can perform
that task so we must have learned it
some testing yeah right and the way
we've learned it is we learn about
characters we learn about words we learn
about sentences we learn about
paragraphs we learn about chapters but
we also learn about tenses we learn
about metaphors we learn about character
development we learn about sarcasm
sarcasm right so with all these things
that we've learned in terms of skills we
were able to go to the next stage and
learn new skills on top of the previous
skills and in machine learning there's
this thing that we call the hypothesis
base we
the space of functions from which we are
looking to find the right function if
the hyperspace is too big then it's too
hard to filter it down to get the right
function but if the space of function is
small enough then with a few labeled
example you can actually find the right
function and the decomposition allows
you to break the problem into this
smallest subspace and once you've
learned that the sub task then you can
compose it and keep going your build on
top of previous skills and now you can
do very complex tasks even though each
of the sub tasks was simple so it is
really more similar to how humans teach
humans then the traditional model of how
we teach machines to learn yes and the
decomposition is also the hallmark of
programming so the art of programming is
decomposition and if you don't get it
right you refactor and we've developed
all these design patterns to do
programming right and believe that there
will be a complete one-to-one
correspondence there will be the design
patterns the teaching language will
correspond to the programming language
and we'll even say that what corresponds
to the assembly language is the machine
learning models and this should be
interchangeable and if they are
interchangeable then the teachers are
interchangeable which is exactly what
you want in terms of productivity
because you know how it works
the person that's taught the project may
not be the person that ends the project
or maintains the project there's been a
lot of talk within the computer science
community about software 2.0 and the
democratization of skills that usually
require a significant amount of
expertise but you've suggested that
those terms don't do full justice to the
kinds of things you're trying to
describe or define so tell us why so if
you said software 2.0 is an evolution
thing right and I believe that we need
something far more radical in the way we
view the problem so to me software is
something that's intentional very often
people in software 2.0 they think about
dealing with large amount of label data
and label data can be collected in a non
intentional way so for instance for
clique prediction the label data is
whether you got a clique or you didn't
get a clique and you collect that
automatically so it's
not really intentional when you write a
program it's very intentional you
decompose it you write each of the
function with a purpose right and I
think when you teach and you decompose
the problem into support the labels are
intentional and they are costly because
they come from a human and now we need
to manage that so if Ida Campos the
problem I want to be able to share the
part that I've decomposed and now if I'm
going to share it I need to version it
and this is a discipline that is very
well-known in programming so how do we
manage as efficiently as possible
knowledge that was created intentionally
and now it will need to be maintained it
will need to be versioning for me to be
shared it will need to be specified and
now all the problems of sharing software
will translate to sharing and
maintaining models that are taught by
humans so the parallel is very very very
direct what about this word
democratization you and I talked before
and I actually inserted the word into
our conversation you know we like that
word yes so I started using that word at
the beginning and I felt like the
problem with the world is that everyone
wants to democratize and I want machine
teaching to be more ambitious so let's
think about the guarantee you have when
you program if I ask you to code a
function and you a programmer you all
tell me yes I can do it and then I'll
say well how long is it going to take
and you're going to say let's say three
months and your estimate may be off
people say that we're usually off by a
factor 3 but you were able to know that
it was possible and you can actually
even specify the performance of your
program and you can say how long it's
going to take right now we don't have
that kind of guarantee when we talk
about machine learning and the strange
thing is that we have all these tools of
a structural risk minimization that
gives us guarantee on the accuracy given
some distribution but we don't really
have guarantee on what the final
performance is going to be before we
have the data and yet in programming we
can have those guarantees so what's
different right so we have to think
about the problem of teaching the
currently and if you start thinking
about the problem of teaching in terms
of decomposition then you'll be able to
reason exactly the same way that your
reason for programming we actually do
this when you teach human right so if
you wanted to teach a concept to a
person and you would say okay this
person doesn't know about this and this
and this one gonna first have to teach
those subscales and then I'll be able to
build on top of these skills so the task
of decomposition is a task that's very
important for teaching we human do it
all the time
we programmer do it all the time the
teacher spent a lot of time decomposing
the problem into these subfield and
subversive on Dacian and building on top
of the foundation and testing at each
level whether you got the scale right
and that testing is exactly what I want
to make a discipline in machine teaching
which is just you know music to my ears
as a former teacher I don't think you
ever stopped being a teacher I said
they'll know I'm dead when the red pen
falls out of my hand well let's get a
little more granular and specific so
you've developed a machine learning tool
called pickle which spelled picl not
like the pickle that you put on a burger
and it stands for platform for
interactive concept learning and it
allows people this is key it allows
people without ml expertise to build ML
classifiers and extractors yes tell us
more about pickle what is it how does it
work and why is it cool okay
so I believe that if you want to do
machine teaching you need a few elements
and if it's okay I'm going to describe
the three elements that I believe are
essential it is okay all right so the
first thing is that you're gonna need a
machine learning algorithm and the
machine learning algorithm has to be
able to find the right function from the
hypothesis base if there is such a
function that fits the data so that's
the first requirement and if we have
that requirement we can even interchange
machine learning algorithms it's not
super important which one are we going
to use the second element I call
teaching completeness and what I mean by
that is that if the teacher can
distinguish two example of two different
class you should be able to give the
Machine a feature that will distinguish
these two classes at the same time
need to be able to compose functions in
a way that you can always bring the
function that you want into the
hypothesis base now it may take several
iteration you may have to create sub
models that are very simple or complex
you can always decompose but eventually
you have to be able to bring the
function that you want in the hypothesis
base and if that's possible then I call
the system teaching complete the last
thing is that you need to have access to
a normal intelligible pool of useful
examples so imagine I want to build a
classifier for gardening and I decide
that the sub concept botanical garden is
important to decide whether it's
gardening or not like maybe if it's
gardening that talks about plants but if
it's botanical garden I said well it's
more about entertainment at gardening
but I need to be able to distinguish
this so now I need a sub classifier to
decide where there's botanical garden or
not and for that I need to find example
for this so if my sampling space has an
infinite supply of all the sub concept
that I may ever learn then basically I
have the ability to find all the example
that I need they're all relevant to the
task that I want so people tend to think
that all that this is a very hard
requirement because how do you get an
infinite supply of data but here is the
key is that that data doesn't need to be
labeled because if I have access to this
pool of unlabeled data I can query it I
can use my classifier to search it I can
combine multiple classifier and say well
this classifier has to be very positive
and this one has to be very negative and
I can sample with that range right so if
I have the right tool to discover the
example that I need I'm good enough so
these are the three requirement and if
you have these three requirement then
it's all about finding the right
combination of labels features
decomposition so that you can achieve
your task and this is what it all does
for text so right now pickle only works
on text interesting and so in pickle you
can take document and classify them but
you can also extract schema from the
document so you can find addresses you
can find
job history from a resume you can find
menus I mean you can extract product you
can extract quotes from email all these
things that human can do very easily so
this is the vision of machine teaching
is that anything you can teach to a
non-expert human you should be able to
teach to a machine and hopefully we have
the language to do that easily now let's
be honest not all humans are good
teachers and I believe that not all
human will be good machine teachers it
takes some education and familiarity
with the tool people but hopefully we
can get better at this
[Music]
I'm delighted by some of the phrases you
use and maybe they're not unique to you
but I find them a little provocative and
I like that one of them is something you
call ml litter it sounds bad what is it
and what can be done about it
okay I'm gonna tell you a story that
I've seen repeated over and over so the
story goes as follows some program
manager decide they're gonna use machine
learning to solve a particular task so
they collect a bunch of data and then
they write their labeling directions and
they send that to get label it comes
back and they look at it and it's not
exactly what they meant with the
labeling directions so they change it a
little bit they send it back the couple
iteration then they finally get data
said that they are happy with they
consult with some machine learning
expert who will be command deep learning
or support vector machine or boosted
decision tree and they will decide what
parameters to use k for validation k
equal five of you know all these hyper
parameters and they will have some
engineers that will do feature
engineering and code some features and
then they finally build a model that
they are happy with the deployed and
it's a catastrophe because cooking
recipes are confused with numerical
recipe and they're missing important
subset of recipe so they go back they do
the iteration they collect more data and
gets label blah blah blah and eventually
they get a function that does exactly
what they want and the super happy means
deployed and everything is fine six
months later the distribution has
changed the semantics of what is a
recipe was not a recipe or whatever they
were trying to do has change the
features that are available are not the
same there are new features some
features on the longer available and
then they go back and they look for the
machine learning expert that machine
learning expert now is at Facebook or
Google Amazon right so you have models
that are no longer reproducible experts
that are not the original expert and so
you can reproduce the model you can
answer the question and someone asked
what can I remove that model and you
remove the model and then sorry everyone
screamed because they're using that
model is a feature for another model but
they don't even know if that feature is
performing to spec
and so you find all these models that
are kind of sort of not defunct they're
still running no one knows whether
they're performing to spec and no one
dare remove them and this is what I call
ML later and the amount of resources
that's wasted on this is enormous now
some people have identified that problem
there's a famous paper from the Google
team on the technical depth that have
identified these problems but I haven't
seen a lot of solutions for how to deal
with this yeah I was gonna ask so I
actually think that machine teaching is
bringing the discipline of programming
to machine learning so something as
simple as using source control and
including in the source control the data
now I mean the software 2.0 according to
my definition which is the intentional
data I don't think we need to version
data that is collected automatically but
everything that is created by a human
with a purpose should be version and in
the same chicken in the same group of
things that you save together you should
include the label the features the
schema everything that's relevant to
reproducing that model and if you do
this and you bring all the discipline
about decomposition and documentation
and versioning then suddenly does solve
that problem you will always be able to
reproduce your models if you bring all
the discipline and design patterns that
we've learned from programming then I
believe that will solve the problem of
ml later I do want to ask you about this
interesting program you told me about
and this program is called the rotation
program and it seems to me like a novel
way to ensure what I would call
organizational hybrid vigor to use an
agricultural or animal husbandry term
what is it why do you think it's a good
thing and what results have you seen
since you implemented it ok so Microsoft
as this organization called Microsoft
Research where the primary goal is to
move the theory forward to this a new
principle and innovate in all the fields
in the product group you have very
different imperatives in terms of
producing value
and the question is how do you transfer
from one organization to the other and
how do you lubricate producing value and
doing innovation and this is not a
simple answer so what I wanted to do is
to help the product group with the
recruiting of research talent I wanted
the researchers to learn about the
reality of power group and you don't
want to force people to do a move that
they don't want to make at the same time
you want to provide the right incentives
so the rotation program is for people
above a certain level they have the
options to do rotation in a product
group with a interesting constraint
which is that they cannot come back for
two years and that constraint means that
when they do that jump they jump in the
deep water and they have to basically
swim for two years and then they have
the option to come back and so two years
is so that they have to review cycle but
it's also so that we can hire a postdoc
during the same time so it all fits
perfectly and what we find out is that
sometimes people come back sometimes
they don't come back every time they do
it at first they say you know I hold to
this contract well like it's my dear
life and after two years they say well
you know I'm totally happy they've given
me a lot of resources and having a huge
amount of impact and suddenly they
absolutely are not worried about the
future and it's very very different so
that's the benefit for the product teams
and the person who goes what's the
benefit for Microsoft Research
so for Microsoft Research there are many
benefits so first having an impact is
always very satisfying the people that
do the jump becomes advocate of research
and collaborators from the product group
so that you can have both a theoretical
impact in the academic community and
have an impact in the real world
basically the world becomes your
customer
it creates movement across the org so it
brings fresh mind legs exactly and so so
this is good in terms of diversity it's
good in terms of basically stirring the
pot a little bit and some people need to
do this
after a while because we all need change
that is such a good transition to
talking about what you're doing right
now moving from Microsoft Research to
what I might call the Microsoft
mothership you're going into Microsoft
Office yes tell us about what prompted
that move what's the goal who are you
taking from here who are you getting
over what's the deal yeah so I started
the machine teaching effort about seven
years ago
and at the time I had the choice of
doing it in a product or doing it in
Microsoft research and to be frank I
worried that if it was done in a product
group it would be hard to protect it
from the imperative of delivering value
right immediately immediately yes yes so
I wanted to have a little bit of
breathing room and so I created this
team in Microsoft Research and now it's
been seven years and I believe that
there's no really any question of the
value we can actually both deliver value
and continue the investment in
innovation and we can do that almost
anywhere in the company so why office
so why office we started doing this in
Asia and now the group that's totally in
Asia has moved to office and basically
I'm rejoining a group that have
influence in the past and we are going
to do both either an office and those
two main products of Microsoft you
started here 20 years ago you said and
your career has been anything but linear
you've been back and forth already the
rotation program is not new to you so
tell us about your path your journey
your story all right so after my PhD I
started at Bell Labs in a pretty famous
group this is the group of young Laocoon
vladimir vapnik yoshua bengio leon bo2
and yoshua and yon just got the Turing
award yeah so I stayed there for eight
years and then I came to Microsoft
Research and when I moved to Microsoft
they did something very strange I looked
at the address book and I looked at
everyone that had the title architect
scheduled one-on-ones and try to find
out what problems need to be solved in
the Prada group it was a very bold kind
of moved and I started creating
relationship and after a while I had two
groups that were providing me with
engineers to help them because they
wanted to have more of my bandwidth and
I told them well the best way to have
more my bandwidth is to provide me with
engineers and then I will help with your
product so that's how I started and then
I thought that you know Microsoft is the
document company because at the time 95%
of all document were created on
Microsoft software and we didn't have a
document group so I said we should have
a document group and then the answer
came back said yeah you should create it
and I said well I'm a machine learning
person I'm not a document person but
after six months I thought it makes no
sense so I created that group and then
more groups were put under me and
eventually I was asked to start live lab
research and this is when I left
Microsoft Research and created live lab
research under Garry flake who was
basically creating life labs so I
created this team and I moved to add
Center as a group program manager and I
can tell you I am not qualified for that
position and it was very crazy and after
six months I sort of fired myself as I
cannot do this and I became a chief
scientist again but after three more
years of that I decided to come back to
Microsoft Research to do machine
teaching and now I'm about to go again
out of Microsoft Research to try to have
an impact all right machine learning is
full of promise and machine teaching
seems to be a promising direction
therein so we might call everything
we've talked about up to now what could
possibly go right but we always have to
ask the what could possibly go wrong
question at least I do not because I'm a
pessimist but because I think we need to
think about unintended consequences and
the power of what we're doing so given
the work you do Patrice and its
potential to put machine learning tools
in the hands of non experts keeps you up
at night
oh yeah I like to think of myself as
someone that thinks strategically and I
feel like it's kind of my job to imagine
everything that can go wrong yes so so
many things can go wrong the first thing
is 30 years ago we had expert system and
you know the first definition of AI and
what happened is that we had these giant
system with lots of rules and we didn't
have a good way to decompose the problem
into simple problem and it didn't work
out we also have now deep learning and
again there's no decomposition and the
complexity is such that we don't
understand what's going on inside and I
think it's far more successful than
where we went thirty years ago and this
is why we have something different today
and I'm trying to say we should be in
between before it was all features no
label and now with deep learning this
sort of kind of all labels no feature
and I'm advocating that we should be in
between and this is where machine
teaching is we should express things not
just with labels but with features and
we should do it in a way that's
discipline and deliberate like we do for
programming okay what if I'm wrong
I don't believe this is the case but of
course I'm worried that am i am i
pulling a whole bunch of people in a
direction that is not the right
direction
at the same time to be honest I really
truly believe that this is the way to go
so I have the fortitude to overcome
those doubts but it's something that
always keeps me up at night the other
question that you're asking is more
philosophical a lot of people have
thought that the key to AI is the
learning algorithm and I actually don't
believe it's the learning algorithm I
think teaching is what makes the
difference so from a philosophical
standpoint I believe that machine
learning algorithm is almost the easy
part is the part that you can locally
optima as teaching is the part that you
have to optimize at a global level at a
societal level and I think that may
actually be the key to AI the same way
it was the key to human
the roadman at the end of every podcast
I give my guests the proverbial last
word so here's your chance to give some
advice or inspiration to emerging
researchers who might be interested in
teaching machines what would you say to
them okay what I tell people when they
ask me advice for career I always tell
them up team ask for growth so challenge
yourself don't be afraid of failure
failure is growth so that's the general
advice for researchers and for people
during their career for machine teaching
a belief machine teaching is an
incredible field right now because first
it's at the intersection of three fields
that are very different so when you are
the intersection of multiple field it's
usually a very fertile ground for doing
all sort of new things I also believe
that we are at a phase transition where
the field of machine learning which is
super popular right is about to transit
to something different and when you are
at the time where transit it's the most
exciting thing possible so I think now
this is a fantastic opportunity to
create a new field I don't know where
it's gonna go but it's very very
exciting
patrice amar thank you so much for
coming on the podcast today all right
thank you it was my pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]
to learn more about dr. Patrice Lamar
and the science of teaching machines
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]